all right hi everyone good morning
welcome I am in the top position of
being the first to go today I am talking
my talks a little different I think than
some of the other talks where people are
kind of showing off a new package or
keep telling about the technique mine is
more about how you use our to saw solve
a concrete problem use something weird
called topic modeling advanced math to
solve a concrete problem that we're
looking into at the Federal Reserve
where I work so the goal here my team is
called risk and surveillance when the
division of consumer and community
affairs so most of the Federal Reserve
looks at Bank in their balance sheets
you know all about the too-big-to-fail
and and then there's the monetary policy
obviously it's even the bigger part but
there is a huge part of the Fed that's
that that sort of looks into and my
division we look at consumer products so
mortgages home loans student loans and
we want to a way of identifying emerging
risks however we did define and risk
good someone to start the timer so I
know what I am so one we have market
data we have data from our examination
team but we also have consumer
complaints and that is a good sort of
real-time way to understand what people
are saying and thinking about their
experience with consumer products so the
Federal Reserve has about 20,000
complaints but this the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau or the CFPB
has over a million complaints and
through our data sharing agreement we
have access to the unredacted narrative
text of these complaints and so that
that's a good source of information it's
just there are some challenges to that
so that when the CFPB was created and
stood up in 2011 I'm gonna it just want
to put a few caveats in here about the
complaints themselves as a data source
so one we know they're not a
representative sample it takes some
effort to actually go and make a
complaint so
this isn't a representative sample of
all our consumers but it does indicate
people who are having a problem
so complaints also vary in their
salience having a problem with someone
on customer service on the telephone
when you have a late fee that you don't
like on your credit card is very
different than having your mortgage
foreclosed on when you're in the process
of working things out with their bank
those things happen they those are just
counted as same complaints and that's
more of a qualitative measure it's a
little hard to do also and the banks
always wants there isn't a caveat this
and other financial services companies
just because someone complains about
something doesn't necessarily mean the
bank didn't anything wrong overdraft
fees everyone hates overdraft fees it's
always the biggest complaint
unfortunately they're the rules allow
banks to charge or overdraft fees as
long as they follow the rules and
regulations that we have around those
and so in our risk analysis we assess
meaningful trends we're not trying to
verify every single complaint as well
and these complaints are only a one
component of an overall risk assessment
of the market in general so when the
CFPB first started you know they had to
start find a process for in taking all
of this data and it's a little hard with
unstructured data on how to try to come
up with a way of classifying these
complaints and so they created a
taxonomy which is what you do you allow
people to identify what they are trying
to complain about it starts with the
product you say you're talking about
your mortgage or your student loan but
within your mortgage you know you may be
complaining about the closing process
but there's just a lot within the the
CFPB's data collection process I'm not
necessarily criticising I'm just saying
there's some limitations to what we have
here so there are about a hundred
thousand credit card complaints there
are 55 issues that you can choose from
that's a lot for people so around 30 of
those have less than 1,000 complaints 15
have less than 500 so you get some
categories that are way too broad like
managing your account for your checking
account promotional offers were one apps
aspect
managing your copy you don't really see
that in the way that they they do this
there are some duplicate or ambiguous
categories like trouble making payments
can both mean I sent my company my my
mortgage check in and they didn't clear
it and I got a late fee versus I lost my
job and my wife got sick and now I can't
afford to make a payment it's a little
hard for both the person who created
that category and the person trying to
classify what their what their complaint
is about to understand which one to the
sting and so fundamentally the way
consumers talk about financial products
may differ from the way that regulators
think about this products and then
there's CFPB didn't realize some of
these limitations in 2017 and
recategorize all of this which improved
the process going forward but it makes
for some very awkward looking time
series graphs when you're looking at it
from my perspective so the solution here
was to use the actual narrative text
itself as the data and use a natural
language processing approach called
topic modeling or latent dare clay
allocation which is a modeling a
Bayesian model that given K number of
topics were iteratively assigned words
to topics and topics of documents as it
updates information contained in the
documents so the general process to
conceptual process how many people are
familiar with topic modeling yeah I had
given this talk before and at the Fed I
have to really tone it down the
technical side I gave of it where I put
in some math in the last one I gave now
I'm gonna put some R code in it I mean
trying to add that smile yeah so the
idea is that you have a set of documents
we call your corpus the LDF it's it's
best topics and you get two
distributions you get a distribution of
words in the topics and then for each
document you have a distribution of
probabilities for topic Simon's so this
is a conceptual example imagine you had
five years worth of newspaper articles
from The Washington Post with no
headlines you create a topic model with
three topics the output could be
election poll moderate health care rules
- goal scorer team fans rules topic 3
theater play drama yeah so this allows
you to identify topics review articles
associated with specific topics and look
at trends in the topics over time
however it doesn't actually replace the
headline of an article so there's a bit
in the way I do this of the actual
modeling process and then some manual
review and I told Tommy this is going to
be a PR for his packaged text miner I
just want to give a quick overview of
kind of delay of the land for NLP
packages in our if you're interested the
biggest challenges in topic modeling are
one understanding the quality of the
model and to selecting the optimal
number of takut topics which is K your
main general NLP packages and our TM
Tidy text quantity' UD pipes is a new
one that I haven't lived into but it's
got some very interesting things text
reuse which is very good for identifying
similarities it has a local sensitivity
hashing that allows you to do it at
scale a little better TM is I just
highly advise not to use it's like the
okay boomer version of topic of NLP it
was good at the time glad you made
inroads I I think David Robinson's here
and he and Julia so he wrote the tiny
text package that's the workhorse one
that I use it's good for all around
understanding a set of documents putting
them into an organized form visualizing
them and transforming them into things
that go into models and so a lot of
these other ones like text of eka store
that was a word glove or word Tyvek word
embeddings version you know the Python
has their version of this snowball see
is forward stemming text rank is sort of
google's pagerank
in tax money anyway within topic
modeling that's the more technical
specialized thing there are the two old
ones that have been around for a while
or Lda and topic
models I've used Lda before it's fine
topic models is a little special
snowflake because you also have to re
index everything to zero because our
into the X's at one it's a little hard
to work you have to understand how to
work with lists rather than data frames
it's a little tricky to use the two that
I I'm still going a little bit back and
forth are on our STM structural topic
modeling and text minor which is when I
use STM is an interesting one that I I'm
happy that I think people should look
into a little more the the reason they
call it structural topic modeling is it
allows you to incorporate metadata into
the topic model so one thing you have to
do when you doing topic modeling is have
some sort of assumption about how topics
are distributed across your corpus this
allows you to say if I had issues which
is how the Steve be categorized as some
of these complaints I can say skew it
it's slightly more toward ones with more
issues the problem for me is I they have
some Diagnostics I've read this paper a
few times there are four Diagnostics I
don't understand them that well I should
maybe go back and read it some more but
the text miner package has two that I
think are pretty more intuitive one is R
squared which is a measure of goodness
of fit it's similar to traditional
regression R squared value Tommy as a
paper that kind of explains this I take
it on faith a little bit with him on
this that it's actually gonna get
published and I can cite it a
probabilistic coherence is a measure of
the quality of the topics there's also a
semantic coherence which is what STM and
a lot of the other ones use I find a
little harder to explain what semantic
coherence is probabilistic coherence is
basically saying if you have what it
looks at the words within that topic and
and sees how well they they work
together as a group in in with us how do
how would I put this so if we go back to
this one and you see topic two is the
goal score team fans rules the the
probability of goal and minus the
probability of score given that go
in that that document that's a measure
of probabilistic coherence so if this
were a topic of just the sports section
it wouldn't be good because going score
would likely to be found in other topics
within within that model I'd it's a
little hard to explain I'm not probably
great at explaining it but it is a
measure that kind of tells you how how
well your topic model is doing and how
what you this k measure should be used
for so here's the process I go through I
use tidy text for the filtering and
building the document term matrix filter
out this this first part is to get the
basic data frame that has a count of
words per document and an also account
of the entire and then the next step is
to get a word frequency count to sort of
edit that down I in this case for the
specific model I took words that
appeared less than 200 times and remove
those and join it back to the original
one and cast it as a data document term
matrix this is the code for this is nice
and that you can run multiple topic
models with different values of K in
parallel Tommy will never be taken to
the school for not making his function
names very obvious that what they do
even if they're very long so TM parallel
apply will and you know you can specify
how many CPUs you have on your machine
to speed this up this is very slow so if
anyone's using this at home it depending
on how big your corpus is can take a
long time to run but it does and then I
use per and GG plots yeah so I'm not a
computer scientist so anytime I get
something of her to actually work it's
kind of a miracle so I'm very proud of
it so and then that allows me to then
look at so which value of K would seem
to be the best one I can pick the topic
model that then when you see the
probabilistic coherence r-squared just
seems to keep going up on most of these
models that I do
but then I stick a step back because
there are some actual practical business
concerns that I have to take into
account I built ten separate models one
for each of these financial products but
Kay's limited at most the 40 topics it's
just hard to explain summarize and
create trend lines for more than that
for the the people that I'm working with
also topic models do output a
distribution of multiple topics so
obviously if you're any a document
you're not always just widening about
one thing but for the purposes of
analysis to avoid double counting and
highlight actual trends I just take the
the first most probable topic for each
document and then it does require some a
neuro view to get a better understanding
of the topics so this is the result of
again for mortgages a similar trend line
the things are going down but you do get
I can see these top terms are just words
compared to the previous time series
it's a better measure and then with some
manual review you can actually get
phrases that fill in what those terms
mean so in general these words also
incorporating the broader risk framework
for our team we we have risk reports
that we use to just understand emerging
risks in these consumer financial
products even if the Fed itself cannot
doesn't oversee these specific products
or these specific institutions we want a
just to know what's going on our
stakeholders are the division director
and even sometimes the board of
governors they want to be aware of
what's going on the marketplace there
are things that we can affect through
rulemaking and policy like that but this
is more of an are just general how to
understand what's going on what issues
consumers are facing a lot of the risk
metrics that that the the bank looks at
are for bank balance sheets we're
looking at it from the consumer
experience what are people what are
areas where people are having trouble
with their credit cards or their student
loan or the mortgage and then I built an
are shiny dashboard that helps users
explore this themselves
I'm not allowed to show that because
anytime a company name shows up on
screen people freak out even though this
is almost all of us is publicly
available information I did want to say
that to start with the CFPB publishes
most of this on the website the only
thing that I get that you don't get is
the actual private narratives so they
only you you can opt into sharing your
complaint publicly 30% of people do that
they read act out PII the good
interesting method for doing that I had
one of my former coworker just actually
have worked on that because I used to
work at the CFPB but I put it back in
that dashboard so all of this
information you can you can go in there
and make your own dashboards and look at
what banks are getting complain about
more often than not but I just am not
allowed to really show that so I do get
a few parting thoughts instead it's just
my general advice and takeaways from
doing applied data science in the
government I haven't worked as a data
scientist in the private sector but
first of all focus on the central
problem and research question not the
technique everyone often they are being
hired for AI or some deep learning that
use you know you have a full toolkit use
the best tool to fit the problem not the
fanciest one engaged with subject matter
experts throughout the process both from
concept form
formation to validation there's no use
in building a cool model that works
really well if no one's gonna use it a
lot of what I do is sort of what I would
characterize as operation this type
research this is more policy analysis
now but at the IRS where I first worked
we would have examination teams and you
say well why don't we try to do a better
job of picking which organizations to
audit and they say well I'm been doing
this 30 years trust me I know like I'm
in tune with you know whatever and
there's intuition and you have to
respect that because they actually do
know that but and you have to work with
them and the validation isn't just
technical validation it's does this have
a useful impact on
I'm doing and make my job easier and one
way to do this is to find low-hanging
fruit fruit to demonstrate value a lot
of times people there's data available
no one's ever looked at it you do a
quick visualization to say hey here's
what you thought was going on here's
what's actually going on maybe that we
should do something about that my big
one that I always tell people who
haven't worked in a lot in data science
applied data science especially in the
government is that change management is
far harder than any data science science
technique you can build a great tensor
flow model but getting people again to
get on board with that evidence that you
showed I both agree with and can that
will now change the way I do my work
almost never happens like that the best
model I saw was at the IRS I worked on a
team that had brought in by the
commissioner some outside consultants
they were part of the government but
they had it sort of this mandate from
the Commissioner and then that allowed
them to get all of the stakeholders the
high-level people that we can often not
reach on to these calls every two weeks
and it would just be hey here's a
problem here's all the data that shows
the problem and every we're going to in
two weeks we're gonna look and do a
little bit more will even run some
experiments this is on identity theft
problem which was a big problem at the
IRS has been improved but so you get
these updates every two weeks you
everyone who has an actual stake in
what's going on to have input into the
process and then if you six months down
the line you say well now we have to
retrain all of our call service
representatives everyone's like well of
course we do whereas if you do all that
analysis yourself and then drop that on
someone they're just gonna roll their
eyes and move on so and sometimes like I
was saying sometimes business
considerations over I've override the
optimal technical solution and that's
okay getting 80% of the way there is and
making allies and getting work in the
future and proving that you have some
value to add is better than the hundred
percent solution and ever get to
implement it so I don't know if this is
just in the government I think it's not
and finally communication visualization
storytelling is crucial this is my plug
for a liberal arts education still I
have a liberal arts education I don't
think everyone has to be like me I just
think between that and social science
background like framing a question
properly but then also being able to
communicate both with visualizations but
also writing clearly and effectively is
as important as the technical skills
which can be learned a little easier
than some of these software skills and
the higher you go up the more important
the soft skills are so that's my the
twitter is personal account
github I have hardly anything on there
because everything is a
enterprise stuff that can't be shared so
I do have an example of what I walk
through here on a unknown data set and
this is kind of what Tommy and I are
like when we run into each other at the
conference all right thank you
[Applause]